Let's pray together over day 30, holiness as
wholeness from Malachi chapter three.
Father, thank you for sending your messenger.
Thank you for the one who sits as the Lord of the covenant.
And we know that no human,
no unholy, sinful person can stand and
endure the day of his coming if we have not been
made clean,
and he comes as a refiner and a purifier.
So Lord, we
submit our heart to the healing whole
purifying work of the Lord of holiness,
Jesus Christ.
We thank you, Lord, for the ability that you have to make
us unmixed.
We want to be that way, Lord.
I pray over my friend who is praying with me here, and
I ask that you would help us to never come to a place where we
say holiness is not important in this area
of my life.
That you would help us to never come to a place where we say,
"I'm going to wall off this part of my life and not let
holiness touch it." Lord, I pray that you would give
a passionate desire for healed
wholeness
so that no area of our life is walled off
or off-limits to the convicting, cleansing,
healing power of the Holy Spirit.
So, Lord, I pray for courage for us to open up
places of our heart that are broken and scarred and
wounded,
perhaps that are infected with bitterness and unforgiveness and that
we've laid aside ever thinking about.
We pray, O God, that you would break down every door and
that you would cleanse out every room, and that you would let there be a
healed wholeness to every part of our mind,
our life, our emotions, our past, our history, our
story, our psyche, everything about us.
We pray in Jesus' name.
I'd encourage you to continue praying and seeking the Lord over
these thoughts that we're having together today.